Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, es wird Zeit, mal wieder über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer zu sprechen. Da ist so einiges passiert und es hört einfach nicht auf, spannend zu sein. Ach, was für eine schöne Liga. Jetzt gleich hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 196. Mein Name ist Max-Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Ich freue mich total, über die 2. Liga zu sprechen. Ist einfach eine schöne Liga. Ich muss mich da wiederholen und ich freue mich sehr, hier zwei Legenden begrüßen zu dürfen. Den einen kennt ihr vielleicht aus einem eigenen Podcast, Rasengeflüster. Auf Twitter ist er der Ed, Jens Umbreit, ich begrüße ihn sehr herzlich hier. Servus, Jens. Ja, und du übernimmst gleich meinen Servus. Ach, da ist einfach der Profi zu erkennen. Ein Chamäleon des Dialektes, der Jens. Da bin ich gespannt, was jetzt dann Florian Zenger zu mir sagt. Ihn kennt ihr von Clubfans United aus der Nürnberger Zeitung und den Nürnberger Nachrichten als EdFloh-Zenger auf Twitter und natürlich auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk.
Servus, Jens.
Servus.
Wir sprechen heute über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer, da ist es spannend wie eh und je. Wie immer machen wir es so, dass wir bei zwei Mannschaften einen kleinen Schwerpunkt setzen, das ist in dem Fall der 1. FC Nürnberg und Dynamo Dresden. Und wir wollen aber auch ein paar andere Vereine zumindest mit ein paar Worten kurz besprechen, die jetzt schon länger hier nicht mehr vorgekommen sind, im Kurzpass. Und da beginnen wir beim Tabellen 2. Werder Bremen führt aktuell die Tabelle an. Auf Rang 2 liegt der HSV-Floh. Wie hat es der HSV dahingeschafft? Und warum haben die alle unentschieden gespielt am letzten Spieltag, die ersten drei?
Wenn man das so einschätzen könnte, warum, weil bei Bremen kann man sich das ja genauso fragen wie bei Darmstadt und bei St. Pauli, die ja dann sogar ordentlich auf die Mütze bekommen haben. Der HSV hat es dahingeschafft, weil er, wenn man sich das mal anguckt, mit Abstand die beste Chancenqualität hat. Also die Chancen, die sie rausspielen, die sind, wenn man jetzt nach den Expected Goals geht, ungefähr 25 Prozent gefährlicher als der Rest. Das trägt dann tatsächlich viel dazu bei, dass die da oben drin sind. Und dazu kommt halt eine gewisse defensive Stabilität, die wirklich ordentlich ist.
Ich finde Kittel und Glatzel, vor allem Glatzel, unheimlich stark. Ich konnte ja den HSV ja Mitte Januar schon in Dresden sehen. Die Tiefe und die Breite des Kaders ist überragend. In Dresden waren sie mir, speziell in der ersten Halbzeit, fast schon zu verspielt, gerade was sie aus der Defensive da gemacht haben. Aber irgendwie hat es Tim Walther hinbekommen. Klar, du hast schon so ein bisschen durchklingen lassen. Sie spielen manchmal einen Tick zu häufig unentschieden und gehen nicht immer all in. Das ist vielleicht so das einzige Manko beim HSV. Aber ich sage mal, der Coach strahlt das geballte Selbstbewusstsein und Selbstvertrauen aus. Es ist jetzt nicht jedermanns Typ, der Tim Walther. Aber ich glaube, er könnte es schaffen, die Phase zu überstehen, die dem HSV in den letzten drei Jahren immer zum Verhängnis geworden ist, nämlich das Frühjahr. Und ja, sicherlich sehr entscheidend wird jetzt der Sonntag werden, dieses Topspiel, dieses Nordderby, auf das sich, glaube ich, die ganze Liga, ganz Deutschland freuen kann. Das wird ein richtig geiles Fußballspiel.
Ach, da bekommt man so richtig Lust. Aber was hat sich denn beim HSV verändert, wenn ich mich erinnere? Flo, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir da auch schon drüber gesprochen haben. Auf jeden Fall war es schon Thema in dieser Saison. Da wurde der Walther-Fußball damals von einem Gast beschrieben, so ein bisschen wie in der E-Jugend. Alle würden den Ball hinterher sprinten. Und das wurde auch sehr deutlich kritisiert. Und jetzt haben wir hier ja nicht nur eine gute Offensive. Das zieht sich wie so ein roter Faden durch das, was zum HSV gesagt wurde, sondern eben auch eine starke Defensive. 21 Gegentore nur. Und damit, ich glaube sogar, die beste der Liga.
Also ich glaube, das hängt ganz viel so ein bisschen mit dem Personal auch zusammen. Also Vuskovic und Schonlau in der Mitte sind halt sehr, sehr stabile Innenverteidiger. Dazu wird halt ein Rechtsverteidiger mit Heier, der vorher auch schon im defensiven Mittelfeld gespielt hat. Also du hast halt sehr defensiv kompakte Leute. Meffert davor auch noch ganz viel vom Personal, die sind sehr abhängig. Und du merkst halt, wie wild das Pressing ist, wenn man die anschaut. Also die setzen halt den Gegner viel unter Stress und damit können halt dann manche Mannschaften auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut umgehen, wenn man auch guckt, wie viel Ballbesitz der HSV dann immer hat, weil sie eben auch schnell sich den Ball wiederholen. Das ist schon auch noch eine Komponente, die mit dazu geht. Und Tim Walther, Jens hat es schon gesagt, der ist als Typ schon nicht immer ganz einfach und sicherlich nicht jedermanns Sache, aber er hat da seinen Walther Ball jetzt quasi so durchgesetzt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, wie gesagt, man muss ihn jetzt nicht unbedingt mögen. Ich glaube, auch in Hamburg ist er jetzt nicht Everybody's Darling, aber er hat momentan den Erfolg. Und ja, aber wie gesagt, jetzt kommt die Phase beim HSV, wo sie liefern müssen. Das Frühjahr ist die entscheidende Phase, wo es jetzt wirklich mal klappen muss, wo es jetzt mal fluppen muss. Und das hat ja in den letzten drei Anläufen nicht funktioniert. Da bin ich sehr neugierig. Ob sie das jetzt wirklich auf die Straße bekommen, auf die Landstraße der 2. Bundesliga, dann könnte es was werden mit dem sogar direkten Aufstieg.
Heieiei, da bekommt man ja jetzt schon Puls. Also am Sonntag spielt der HSV zu Hause gegen Werder. Werder führt die Tabelle der 2. Bundesliga der Männer an mit 42 Punkten, der HSV 41 Punkte, dahinter Darmstadt 41 Punkte, St. Pauli auch bei 41 Punkten. Die haben verloren, das haben wir schon angesprochen, gegen Hannover 96, jetzt auch nicht unbedingt das, was gleich zu erwarten war, aber das ist halt typisch 2. Liga aktuell. Schalke dann mit 40 Punkten dahinter, also die ersten 5, innerhalb von 3 Punkten, 42 bis Punkte. Richtig schön eng ist es da gerade. Und danach Jens kommt Heidenheim mit 38 Punkten. Die mussten jetzt ein bisschen abreißen lassen. Die waren, wenn ich so ehrlich sein darf, auf meiner internen Rangliste immer so die heimlichen Favoriten, weil ich Heidenheim als so stabil einschätze, weil es da einfach gewisse Konstanten gibt, die immer da sind. Hast du eine Antwort darauf, warum das jetzt in den letzten beiden Spielen mit einer Niederlage und einem Unentschieden nicht der Fall war?
Na ja, ich habe sie am Freitag gesehen gegen Dynamo Dresden. Und ich gebe dir recht, Max, sie sind auch für mich immer noch das Dark Horse im Aufstiegsrennen. Auch immer so ein bisschen latent unterschätzt, weil es eben, ja, es ist Heidenheim. Aber Frank Schmidt arbeitet dort seit vielen, vielen Jahren sehr, sehr erfolgreich. Und ich würde die Heidenheimer wirklich tatsächlich noch nicht abschreiben. Was mir in Dresden aufgefallen ist, ist, dass sie es nicht über 90 Minuten hinbekommen haben. Und dass sie speziell nach dem Ausgleich, nach diesem Elfmetertor, was Frank Schmidt gesagt hat, für ihn kein Elfmeter gewesen ist, was sicherlich ein umstrittener Elfmeter gewesen ist, dass sie dann komplett abreißen lassen haben. Ihnen hat natürlich Kleindienst speziell am Freitag gefehlt. Seine sieben Treffer, das ist ja der beste Torschütze beim 1. FC Heidenheim. Aber am Freitag haben sie dann, wie gesagt, nur 20, 30 Minuten ordentlich offensiv gespielt, nämlich zu Beginn der 1. Halbzeit war es gar nichts von beiden Mannschaften. Und am Schluss müssen sie dann sogar noch sagen, ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch, wir nehmen hier wenigstens einen Punkt aus Dresden mit. So ehrlich muss man sein. Und vielleicht leisten sie sich jetzt auch so ein bisschen zur Unzeit eine kleine Delle, eine Formdelle.
Es ist ganz spannend, weil ich in der Vorbereitung zur Sendung mir die Highlights rausgelassen habe von dem Spiel und mich gewundert habe, dass ich aus der 1. Halbzeit gar nichts hatte. Zu Recht. Und das unterstreicht es nochmal. Ich finde es ganz spannend, wenn du Heidenheim anschaust, die haben relativ viele Standard-Tore, haben dazu dann noch relativ viele Konter-Tore. Aber wenn du die Positionsangriffe nimmst, also quasi aus dem Spiel rauskommen, die nur auf 13 Tore, haben eh nur 29 geschossen, was jetzt in der Spitzengruppe eh schon das wenigste ist. Und wenn man dann eben Standards und Konter noch wegnimmt, dann bleibt nicht mehr viel übrig. Und das ist, denke ich, so ein bisschen auch das Manko. Du hast es zum Kleindienst schon angesprochen. Das ist so der, der da vorne drin noch für was sucht und dann sonst sorgt. Aber sonst ist es halt aus dem Spiel raus. Es ist halt so ein bisschen dieses Frank-Schmidt-Ding. Wir spielen schnell nach vorne und dann funktioniert es aber aus dem Spiel raus. Es ist schon schwierig. Ich bin aber auch der Meinung, die haben diesen großen Vorteil. Die haben eine sehr, sehr enge Gruppe. Also wenn man sich das anschaut, es gibt acht Spieler, die mehr als 80 Prozent der möglichen Einsatzzeit haben. Also eine sehr, sehr starke Truppe, was die Stammformation angeht. Die wissen, was sie tun. Und wenn da dann einer natürlich auch rausfällt, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Kleindienst, dann merkt man das auch relativ schnell. Aber sie sind halt eingespielt. Und Frank Schmidt lässt halt auch schon seit Jahren so ungefähr dasselbe spielen. Und deshalb, ich würde die auch noch nicht abschreiben, weil ich meine, drei Punkte auf dem zweiten und vom ersten und vom zweiten werden nicht beide gewinnen.
Ja, aber sie kommen natürlich auch über die Füße. Wie eh und jeder 1. FC Heidenheim. Mit ihren knapp 120 Kilometern, die sie da als Mannschaft abreißen, sind sie ja die laufstärkste Truppe. Das hat man auch am Freitag gemerkt, dass sie da wirklich viel über die Füße machen. Das war zu sehen. Aber man will ja in der ersten Halbzeit keine Laufeinheiten sehen. Sondern Chancen. Und die waren eben am Freitagabend komplett Mangelware. Die erste Halbzeit, wer die sich nochmal angucken will, der fehlt sich eben auch persönlich. Und das braucht man wirklich nicht. Das war wirklich dein erstes Spiel, was man sich in der zweiten Halbzeit antun konnte.
Ich muss, glaube ich, an der Stelle, wenn ich darf, Flo, schon mal das vorweggreifen, was du uns geschickt hast. Der Flo hat Hausaufgaben gemacht, die er nicht aufhatte. Er hat uns unverlangt sehr spannende Diagramme zugeschickt, Jens und mir. Unter anderem der Anteil der Neuzugänge an gespielten Minuten. Ich nehme an, dass das sich auf die gesamte Saison bezieht, und nicht nur auf den Spieltag. Und da ist nämlich Heidenheim wirklich ein krasser Ausreißer. Also nur 2,5 Prozent aller Minuten wurden von Neuzugängen absolviert. In dieser bisherigen Saison nur so zum Vergleich. Wahrscheinlich liegt der Ligaschnitt irgendwo bei 35 Prozent. Schalke zum Beispiel ist da das ganz andere Extrem mit 77 Prozent. Aber als ich das gesehen habe und als ich mir dann auch angeguckt habe, wie die letzten Wochen für Heidenheim verlief, hatte ich das Gefühl, vielleicht fehlen da auch die Impulse von außen. So gut dieses stabile System bei Heidenheim ist, fehlt vielleicht das, was andere Mannschaften haben. Dieser X-Faktor mit Dux zum Beispiel, mit Glatzl, mit Lieberknechts Hinrunde bei Namestadt, mit Timo Schulz. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt für jeden Verein so runterbrechen kann, aber bei Heidenheim würde mir eben als X-Faktor wieder nur die Standards einfallen. Und vielleicht ist das Teil des Problems.
Ja, wenn man das aufdröselt, Heidenheim hatte vor der Saison nur zwei Neuzugänge. Mit Ciersleben, der jetzt auf 137 Minuten an 23 Spieltagen kommt, und mit Malone, der auf 456 Minuten kommt. Das ist halt nicht wahnsinnig viel, wenn du bedenkst, dass du die maximale Minutenzahl bei Heidenheim bei 2180 läge. Die spielen nicht viel, sondern es spielen halt die Leute, die schon länger da sind. Ich habe Kleindienst mal nicht als Neuzugang gewertet, weil der ja letztes Jahr in der Rückrunde ausgeliehen war und jetzt dann fest verpflichtet wurde. Das sind ja auch so Sachen. Aber ich sehe das schon als Problem. Du hast Kleindienst, der, wenn er läuft, so wie letztes Jahr in der Rückrunde schon der X-Faktor sein kann. Aber ansonsten hast du diesen engen Kreis und du hast vor allem auch wenig Impulse dann von außen, die dann noch mal reinkommen können und dann noch mal was verändern. Selbst so jemand wie Kevin Sessa oder so, der schon immer so ein bisschen auch hieß, der könnte was werden, sieht relativ wenig Einsatzzeit. Also das ist dann schon ein Problem, das stimmt. Andererseits kann es natürlich auch von Vorteil sein, wenn man sich kennt und weiß, wie die Abläufe sind.
Ja, das denke ich nämlich auch. Also so eine eingespielte Truppe, die macht ja schon irgendwas her. Und Max, du hast gesagt, ja, jetzt eine Niederlage und ein Unentschieden. Ich sag mal, beim HSV darf man auch mal verlieren und in Dresden darf man auch mal Unentschieden spielen. Also da würde ich eben auch ein bisschen für mich im Dorf lassen. Ich finde, entscheidend ist jetzt Sandhausen, das Heimspiel. Wenn du da gewinnst, bleibst du weiter drin. Und dann ist das eben nicht nur ein Fünfkampf, wie es jetzt einige Medien schreiben und erzählen, sondern dann ist es weiterhin ein Sechskampf. Vielleicht macht der Flo ja auch einen Siebenkampf daraus.
Ja, genau die Frage stellen wir doch jetzt mal dem Flo. Weil du hast ja völlig recht, Jens, man darf gegen den HSV auch durchaus mal verlieren. Darf man denn auch, lieber Flo, auch gegen Ingolstadt verlieren zu Hause mit 0 zu 5? Darf man denn auch in Kaisere verlieren mit 1 zu 4? Ich möchte gerne mit dir über den 1. FC Nürnberg sprechen.
Jetzt hast du die Einschränkungen genannt. Wir werden nicht darüber sprechen, aber der neue FC Ingolstadt ist durchaus eine Mannschaft, die problematisch für Gegner sein kann, weil da so viel durchgetauscht worden ist. Da sind wir genau an dem Punkt. Weil die haben ja im Winter so viel gewechselt, dass man auch sagen kann, das hat nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel mit der Mannschaft aus der Hinrunde zu tun, auch mit neuem Trainer und so weiter. Also, man kann gegen Ingolstadt schon verlieren, aber die Art und Weise, wie dann da mit 0 zu 5 verloren worden ist und das Ganze dann eben dann gefolgt von noch mal einem 1 zu 4 in Karlsruhe, das war dann schon, was das ziemlich bedenklich gestimmt hat, zumindest im ersten Moment. Also gerade die Niederlage gegen Ingolstadt, da war Robert Klaus auch selber der Meinung, dass das nicht so hinzunehmen ist. Da hat er auch ganz untypisch für ihn, der ja sehr, sehr analytisch und sehr, sehr taktisch geprägt ist, auch die Einstellung bemängelt. Und wenn er das tut, dann weiß man, da liegt ganz schön viel im Argen. Er hat es dann ein bisschen zurückgenommen nach dem Karlsruhespiel. Da kann man ihm in gewisser Weise durchaus auch folgen, weil das Karlsruhespiel schon eins war, das an zwei, drei Stellen auch in die andere Richtung kippen kann. Da gibt es eine Chance von Manuel Schäffler direkt nach der Pause, wo O'Shaughnessy über den Ball haut und dann steht er frei vor Gersbeck und schießt ihn halt an und trifft nicht das Tor. Kurz vor dem 1.1 hat Tim Handwerker nach einer Ecke eine Chance. Da kann ich mitgehen, dass man sagt, das muss man ein bisschen differenzierter sehen. Andererseits sind sie dann auch hinten raus, gerade nach dem 1.2 und 1.3 ganz schön auseinandergebrochen. Also von daher, ja, man kann durchaus verlieren, aber halt vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf die Art und Weise.
Und was sagt das jetzt über die Chancen des 1. FC Nürnberg über den Saisonverlauf? Du hast es ja jetzt schon eingeordnet, ich finde, man muss das jetzt nicht überbewerten, aber man muss auch feststellen, dass diese zwei Niederlagen, denen jetzt allerdings auch ein Sieg gefolgt ist, das will ich nicht unterschlagen, aber die sind halt genau in dieser Phase geschehen, in der jetzt andere Mannschaften aufgedreht haben und in dem sich da oben jetzt schon einiges neu sortiert hat, ohne dass das in fünf Spieltagen genauso aussieht. Aber man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, Mensch, das ist jetzt genau die falsche Zeit, um sich so zwei richtige Klöpper reinzuholen. Wo, glaubst du, steht der Club mit Blick aufs Ausstiegsrennen?
Ja, ich glaube, wenn man sich auch die Spiele davor anschaut, man hat seit November immer Sieg, Niederlage, Sieg, Niederlage, Sieg, Niederlage abwechselnd. Und genau das beschreibt den FCN ganz gut. Wir hatten es ja jetzt auch, jetzt waren halt mal zwei Niederlagen und jetzt kam dann der Sieg. Also die fehlende Konstanz ist eigentlich die Konstanz beim FCN, zumindest in den Ergebnissen. Dass immer wieder kommt man an den Punkt, dass man vielleicht denkt, jetzt wären wir vielleicht dran, jetzt ist man ja auch wieder an den Punkt. Man kann ja ja fünf Punkte auf den zweiten. Alles noch drin. Andererseits, wenn man sich so die Spiele anschaut und auch anschaut, wie man gespielt hat und auch wie man vorgeht, ist man halt nicht so weit, dass man sagen kann, man kann da wirklich noch aktiv eingreifen, es sei denn, es verändert sich jetzt noch was. Also dieses Regensburg-Spiel, das du schon angesprochen hast, das war ja dann in vielerlei Hinsicht plötzlich dann doch ganz anders. Also sowohl von der Grundordnung her, man hat dann plötzlich 4-2-3-1 gespielt, wenn man vorher immer 4-4-2 mit Raute gespielt hatte oder auch mal versucht hat, mit 4-3-3 zu spielen. Also man hat es so ein bisschen variiert. Man hat dann, Robert Klaus hat den dann gleich einen neuen taktischen Begriff reingebracht, hat gesagt, wir haben mit mobilen Zehnern, mit drei mobilen Zehnern gespielt. Also das wären Lukas Schleimer, Thailand Duman und Mats Möller-Deli. Jetzt werden die Hörer und Hörerinnen wahrscheinlich denken, ja bei zwei von denen auch noch sich fragen, wer das ist. Und genau das ist es. Das sind gerade Duman und Schleimer. Schleimer kommt aus der eigenen U21, ist von Dieter Nüssing bei Mosella Schweich in der Nähe von Trier entdeckt worden. Also so ein ganz obskurer Verein, der hat den da rausgeholt in die Nürnberger U19. Der war dann nach Saarbrücken ausgeliehen, war eigentlich schon weg und hat sich dann im Training wieder angeboten, Thailand-Dumann, kommt über den zweiten Bildungsweg, der ist von Düsseldorf ausgebildet, war dann in der zweiten Mannschaft von Borussia Dortmund, war da Rechtsverteidiger oder rechter Wingback und ist jetzt da mit dazugekommen. Und die zwei sind halt sehr wild und vielleicht auch in der Defensivbewegung nicht immer so zuverlässig, aber sie haben halt von ihren Bewegungen und von ihrem Zug nach vorne sehr, sehr viel Gutes getan und damit auch Regensburg unter Stress gesetzt. Und ich glaube, das war dann auch das Entscheidende in der Phase, dass man dann eben da durch diesen Stress sie nochmal ein bisschen, ein bisschen was verändert hat. Und das ist jetzt die Frage, geht man diesen Weg jetzt mehr? Weil das große Problem bei Nürnberg in den letzten Wochen war eigentlich, dass Chancen kreieren, also man hat halt wenig gute Chancen sich erarbeitet. Dieses 4-4-2 mit Raute war auch sehr statisch in vielen Dingen. Man hat dann mit Schurranoff und Schäffler teilweise auch vorne drin zwei Angreifer gehabt, die auch sehr statisch waren, die kaum am Spiel partizipiert haben. Und das alles war eben dann so ein Faktor, wahrscheinlich auch, warum Robert Klaus sich dann gedacht hat, wir probieren mal was anderes. Jetzt hat es gegen Regensburg einigermaßen gut funktioniert. Und jetzt ist eben die Frage, wenn sich das verändert, dann könnte sich schon noch mal was nach oben verändern. Andererseits ist eben dieses Wechseln zwischen Sieg und Niederlage schon so ein bisschen das Markenzeichen im zweiten Saisondrittel gewesen. Und es ist eben jetzt die Frage, legt man das ab? Dann kann man sicherlich oben noch mal reingehen. Ich persönlich glaube es aber einfach nicht. Also dafür ist die Mannschaft halt dann doch an vielen Stellen zu wenig konstant.
Aber, Florian, dass ich hier mal einhacke, ist es nicht wichtig für den Club jetzt eine Fortentwicklung und einen Fortschritt zur letzten Saison zu sehen? Für Robert Klaus als auch für Dieter Hecken. Und der ist ja wohl zu sehen. Und ist es nicht auch wichtig, mit Rückschlicken gut umzugehen, wie sie es jetzt gemacht haben? Du hast die Niederlagen gegen Karlsruhe und Ingolstadt genannt, dass man jetzt eben geantwortet hat im Heimspiel gegen Regensburg. Da sehe ich ja Fortschritte im Vergleich zur Vorsaison.
Das war jetzt auch nur auf Max Frage nach dem Aufstieg bezogen an sich.
Und wenn du es diese Saison nicht schaffst, machst du es nächste Saison. Oder kreist es dann richtig an? Weil wir wissen ja alle, wie brutal schwer die Saison in dieser Spielzeit ist, in der 2. Liga aufgrund der ganzen Etabli oder aufgrund der ganzen namhaften Vereine mit Bremen, Schalke und Hamburg. Da werden ja welche hochgehen. Davon kann es ja fest ausgehen. Und vielleicht hast du dann nächstes Jahr die Möglichkeit, gerade nach einem 3-Jahres-Plan richtig anzugreifen.
Der interne Plan sieht sicherlich auch so aus. Man hat am Anfang der Saison ganz klar gesagt, man will irgendwo zwischen 5 und 8 landen. Da sind sie voll auf Kurs. Und ich gehe auch fest davon aus, dass das genau das ist, wo sie einlaufen werden. Und man will dann –das haben sie natürlich noch nicht so formuliert –im dritten Jahr angreifen. Man hat ja da auch schon ein bisschen neu eingekauft für die neue Saison. Also der Bruder von Danny Blum kommt von –Sean Blum kommt von Kaiserslautern, Erik Weckesser kommt aus Regensburg. Das ist ja alles schon in trockenen Tüchern. Also man hat da schon so ein bisschen weiter geplant. Es gibt halt Unwägbarkeit. Tom Kraus geht nach Leipzig zurück oder geht nach Leipzig und wird dann vielleicht wieder woanders hin verliehen. Du hast die Lino Tempelmann, der ausgeliehen ist, wo du auch nicht weißt, sagt Freiburg nach einem Jahr, wir wollen ihn wieder haben oder nicht dazu. Klar, Erich Schoranow hat verlängert, aber er ist einer von denen, die man am Ersten noch zu Geld machen kann. Jetzt leidet der FC N wahrscheinlich etwas mehr als andere Vereine aufgrund der Struktur unter den Zuschauerausfällen oder an den Einnahmeausfällen. Das sind halt alles so Unwägbarkeiten, die zusätzlich noch mit drin sind, weshalb es vielleicht etwas schwieriger wird, zu sagen, wir greifen nächstes Jahr auf jeden Fall an. Andererseits, man weiß nicht, wie es aussieht, aber der Plan ist sicherlich so, dass man sagt, wir bauen jetzt diese Saison auf, wir schauen, dass die Entwicklung feststellbar ist. Stand jetzt ist es sowohl punktetechnisch als auch bis zum gewissen Grad auch spielerisch feststellbar, dass sich da was entwickelt hat. Dementsprechend ist dann im nächsten Jahr der nächste Schritt. Aber ich glaube, um den Bogen zu Max Frage zu spannen, ob man da einen Siebenkampf noch draus machen kann, das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr. Also ich glaube nicht, dass der Club so konstant ist, dass er oben rein geht.
Und wenn ich mal so kurz revue-palisieren lasse, was wir bisher so über den 1. FC Nürnberg hier in den Kurzpässen gehört haben, hatten wir immer schon einen Zweiklang. Zum einen das ungewohnte Gefühl, dass es am Anfang der Saison nur sieben Gegentore gab. Damals sieben Mal zu Null hatte man gespielt nach elf Spieltagen. Das ist nicht auf diesem Niveau geblieben, aber immer noch würde ich sagen, die Abwehr gehört mit zu den positiven Dingen beim 1. FC Nürnberg. Und schon damals haben wir aber über die fehlende Torgefahr gesprochen, die du jetzt hier auch noch mal angesprochen hast. Und der Klub liegt da mit 32 geschossenen und 32 kassierten Toren so im Durchschnitt der Liga. Das ist so graue Maus-Bilanz, nicht nur weil es insgesamt miteinander aufgerechnet Null ergibt. Wo siehst du denn die größeren Probleme? Ist es das von dir angesprochene Herausspielen von Chancen oder könnte man diese Konstanz nicht auch viel, also ein bisschen einfacher darüber erreichen, dass man die Defensive stabilisiert?
Also die in den letzten Wochen lag, man muss da so ein bisschen gucken, weil von den 32 sind natürlich neun Gegentore auf diesen zwei genannten Spielen. Und in den Spielen ist es halt auch so, jetzt hat zweimal Christopher Schindler gefehlt, vorher hat einmal Eska Sörensen gefehlt. Also Sörensen und Schindler sind eigentlich so das Innenverteidiger-Duo, dass das sehr, sehr stabil ist. Da musste dann mit Mario Schuwa zweimal jemand verteidigen, der vielleicht noch nicht auf dem Niveau ist, dass er das konstant spielen kann. Und ist dann halt auch noch fortgespült worden in diesem Ingolstadt-Spiel von dem Anrennen der Ingolstädter. Dementsprechend, das gehört natürlich auch mit dazu, dass man das so ein bisschen berücksichtigt. Ich denke generell, wenn man auf die Abwehr guckt, muss man wahrscheinlich sagen, dass da so ein bisschen Tempo fehlt in der Innenverteidigung und auch gerade so im Vorfeld, im defensiven Mittelfeld. Weil Johannes Geiss, der ja da normal spielt, jetzt auch nicht mit Tempo gesegnet ist. Das Gleiche gilt für Enrico Valentini auf der rechten Seite, der aus anderen Gründen, aber jetzt sagen wir mal für den Verein und die Mannschaft durchaus wichtig ist, aber der halt da auch seine Defizite hat. Also das ist das eine zum anderen. Aber ich denke, dass man sich eher auf das Offensive konzentrieren muss, weil wenn man dann so anguckt, man ist sehr ungeduldig im Abschluss. Also ich habe mal nachgeguckt, es gibt keine andere Mannschaft, die vom Schnitt her weiter weg vom Tor abschließt als der Club. Das sind mehr als 20 Meter. Das hat keine andere Mannschaft, hat im Schnitt eine weitere Distanz und das liegt nicht daran, dass Nicola Dovelan ab und zu aus 50 Metern aufs Tor schießt, sondern das ist tatsächlich so ein strukturelles Problem, dass man dann irgendwann nervös wird und das nicht zu Ende spielt, sondern zu früh abschließt und man hat halt auch die neumodische Begriff, die Boxbesetzung, also dass die Stürmer in den Strafraum kommen und da dann tatsächlich auch was mit anfangen können. Das fehlt halt gerade, wenn Schuranoff und Schäffler beide auf dem Platz stehen, fehlt das schon häufig. Dann werden die im Aufbau oft rausgezogen, dann tauchen die so im 10er-Raum oder noch tiefer auf und dann wird es schon schwierig, also da dann so viel zu kreieren und das ist halt sehr, sehr viel abhängig. Oder war jetzt, das Regensburgspiel mal ausgenommen, war halt immer viel von Mats Möller-Deli alleine abhängig, der da auf der 10 in dem 4-4-2 gespielt hat und dann die Steckpässe alleine von ihm, das ist natürlich schwierig, wenn man dann so sehr von einer Person abhängig ist, die noch dazu jetzt kein Abschlussspieler ist. Also Mats Möller-Deli ist eigentlich am schwächsten, wenn er in den Abschluss selber muss, weil da wird er dann, wenn er das Tor selber sieht, wird er genauso nervös und zieht vielleicht etwas zu früh ab. Und dementsprechend, also da ist vielleicht auch die Idee, die man da jetzt hatte, mit Duman und mit Schleimer zusätzlich noch gar nicht so schlecht, dass man Möller-Deli noch andere Leute zur Seite stellt. Und man hat dann jetzt gegen Iniane auch mit Pascal Köpke vorne drin gespielt, also auch einen mobiler Rennstürmer, der mehr tiefe Läufe macht.
Also drei mobile Zehner und noch ein mobiler Stürmer, alles im Wandel, das ist ja hart.
Ganz wild, also wir haben in KDEP in unserem Podcast für nordbayern.de auch so besprochen, das ist halt sehr, sehr volatil, fluide, polyvalent, da gibt es so wunderbar schöne Begriffe. Ich habe es einfach als wild bezeichnet, weil genau das ist es letztlich. Es war sehr, sehr wild mit vielen Bewegungen, wo auch nicht alles klappt. Und das ist halt gegen Regensburg, wir kommen später noch dazu, da geht es momentan, jetzt am Wochenende wird es gegen Rostock gehen, da könnte das auch ein ganz gutes Mittel sein, aber wenn dann der HSV in zwei Wochen kommt, ist es vielleicht schon wieder das falsche Mittel.
Ja, wobei Wildheit mit Wildheit zu bekämpfen, also zumindest für den neutralen Zuschauer und die neutrale Zuschauerin steckt da einiges drin, finde ich. Aber wir wissen ja welcher, dass es nur einen Stürmer europaweit gibt, der dann das Ganze wieder ins Gleichgewicht bringen könnte, natürlich Giro Immobile.
Danke, dass du gelacht hast.
Der musste noch kommen, da konnte ich einfach nicht anders. Und ich kann jetzt auch nicht anders, als jetzt dann auf den SC Paderborn überzuleiten, denn die liegen hinter den Klubberinnen, haben allerdings schon vier Punkte Rückstand. Also da ist so ein bisschen der Cut in der Tabelle, spätestens da, würde ich sagen. Jens, wie gefällt dir Paderborn? Was sind da so aktuell die Dinge, die man wissen muss? Es läuft ja ergebnistechnisch nicht so gut.
Wenn es in der zweiten Liga noch den UE Cup gäbe oder wenn es den überhaupt gegeben hätte, dann würden sie vielleicht um die Platzierung spielen. Also ich sag mal, die sind jenseits von gut und böse. Das muss man ja schon ganz klar so sagen. Quasniok, der Trainer, ist ja auch schon danach gefragt worden, um was geht es denn jetzt so wirklich? Na, er hat ja gesagt, es geht immer um etwas, es geht um drei Punkte. Das ist schon ganz klar. Sicherlich ist die Heimschwäche Grund dafür, dass sie eben dort stehen, wo sie jetzt stehen. Sonst würden sie nämlich weiter oben platziert sein und möglicherweise auch noch mit eingreifen können ins Aufstiegsrennen. Nur zwei Heimsiege sind einfach zu wenig und wir werden sicherlich darüber reden. Sven Michel ist ihnen natürlich abhanden gekommen. Der ist bei Union Berlin und den können sie nicht kompensieren. Ihr habt mich ja vorhin mal angeguckt, der führt immer noch in der Scorerliste. Er ist schon längst nicht mehr beim SC Paderborn, aber mit seinen 14 Toren und acht Vorlagen ist er eben immer noch der beste Scorer in der 2. Bundesliga. Und den kannst du als SC Paderborn einfach nicht kompensieren und ersetzen. Das habe ich auch im Spiel gegen Dynamo Dresden gesehen. Das war ja fast ein typisches 0 zu 0. Da hast du ganz deutlich gemerkt im Vergleich, zum Hinspiel oder zum Pokalspiel gegen Dynamo, dass ihm dieser offensive Sprung momentan komplett abhandengekommen ist.
Ja, das ist ja auch dann spannend, dass Lukas Kwasniok in einem Spiel probiert hat, mit Heuer einen Innenverteidiger vorne reinzustellen in den Sturm, weil er keine andere Idee mehr hatte. Er hat seine Stürmer draußen gelassen, hat für über eine Stunde einen Innenverteidiger vorne drin gehabt, weil er eben nicht so recht wusste, wie er jetzt damit umgeht. Michl war ja noch in Nürnberg, da habe ich ihn ja noch gesehen, da hat er noch für Paterborn gespielt und war da schon der absolute Unterschiedsspieler. Ich glaube, da ist das war dann auch so ein bisschen die Frage, ist es das wirklich wert, was man da gekriegt hat? Man hat wahrscheinlich von Anfang an gesagt, ja, mit dem Aufstieg wird es nichts, also nehmen wir das Geld mit. Aber es ist schon bezeichnend, wie viel da an Klasse auch damit verloren gegangen ist. Jetzt fehlt halt dieser Abschlussspieler wirklich komplett.
Und das können sie einfach nicht wettmachen, das sieht man beim SC Paterborn. Aber ich glaube, die planen jetzt auch schon mit Blick auf die nächste Saison. Die wissen, die werden drinbleiben, die wissen, sie werden auch nicht mehr groß ins Ausstiegsrennen eingreifen. Und deshalb sind sie –Max hat ja vorhin gesagt, so eine typische graue Maus –jetzt wahrscheinlich in dieser Saison. Und das kann aber trotzdem für die Gegner auch unangenehm sein, weil die können manchmal auch ziemlich locker und dann in die Partien reingehen. Das kann gerade im Saisonendsport auch für wilde Ergebnisse sorgen.
Ja, stimmt. Gerade bei der Spielweise von Paterborn ist das natürlich ein guter Grund. Aber es ist schon –ich weiß es nicht –es ist total nachvollziehbar. Man hat mit den 32 Punkten ja wirklich sehr wahrscheinlich muss man sich um den Abstieg keine Sorgen mehr machen und man sieht aber auch, was an der Tabellenspitze passiert. Und dann nehme ich natürlich die Millionen, die ich vom 1. FC Union bekomme, für Sven Michel mit. Und trotzdem ist es so ein bisschen schade aus Perspektive der Liga, weil das ja auch was aussagt. Das hat ja Abstrahleffekte auf alle eigentlich. Wenn eine Mannschaft es sich erlauben kann, am 23. Spieltag –und ja eigentlich schon früher, sie haben die Entscheidung ja schon früher getroffen– zu sagen, wir brauchen das eigentlich jetzt nicht mehr. Das ist ja, ich weiß nicht. Also es ist eine total spannende und tolle Liga, aber solche Elemente möchte man ja eigentlich in einem sportlichen Wettbewerb nicht mit drin haben.
Aber die große Frage ist natürlich, wie hätten sie reagiert, wenn sie jetzt zum Beispiel Dritter gewesen wäre? Hätten sie dann auch gesagt, wir nehmen die Kohle? Oder hätten sie dann gesagt, nee, wir behalten Sven Michael? Er wollte ja selbst auch weg, also das muss man ja auch dazu sagen.
Ja, wichtiger Punkt, hast du recht. Na gut, dann wollen wir das vielleicht auch nicht größer machen als es ist. Bin gespannt, wie viel wir über den SC Paderborn noch sprechen werden. In diesen Zweitliga-Kurzpässen, die jetzt noch verbleiben werden, würde ich jetzt nicht alles Geld draufwetten, dass die noch ausführlich zum Sprechen kommen. Da wird es dann schon interessanter, wie oft wir Flo noch über den SSV Jan Regensburg sprechen werden. Da hast du vorhin schon immer mal wieder so kleinere Brücken gebaut, hast gesagt, über die werden wir ja auch gleich sprechen. Du hast sie jetzt ja auch noch mal wegen des Klubspiels enger im Blick gehabt. Ich erinnere mich, der Jan war so ein bisschen die Überraschung der Saison-Anfangsphase. Da hatten wir viel auch darüber gesprochen, dass da eine Kontinuität da ist. Die anderen Mannschaften damals ganz klar gefältert, nicht nur auf Trainerposition, sondern auch, was die verfügbaren Spieler und auch die Spielart anging. Jetzt hat sich das alles ein bisschen eingependet bei Regensburg, mit einer allerdings wirklich sehr schmerzhaften Siegesserie. Also übergreifend haben wir in den letzten sechs Partien fünf Niederlagen für Regensburg. Kannst du mir erklären, warum?
Wenn ich jetzt von Regression zur Mitte spreche, dann weiß ich nicht, ob man damit wahnsinnig viel anfangen kann. Aber es ist ganz spannend, das ist halt das, was man immer sagt. Es gleicht sich im Fußball alles aus. Es scheint tatsächlich ein bisschen so zu sein, weil am Anfang der Saison war schon eine U-Bow-Performance auch da. Das muss man schon auch ganz klar sagen. Und jetzt läuft es halt auch mal doof. Das Spiel am Wochenende war schon das beste Beispiel dafür, wo du siehst, der Klub macht eigentlich mehr oder weniger mit dem ersten Abschluss, wo die Verteidigung auch ein bisschen schläfrig ist. Sofort ist 1-0. Vorher und nachher kann Regensburg an zwei, drei Stellen auch das Tor machen. Und macht es halt nicht. Das ist tatsächlich so etwas, wo ich sage, manchmal kann man es ein bisschen mit Glück oder Pech erklären. Und ansonsten ist es eben so, sie sind ein bisschen flexibler in der Herangehensweise geworden. Also sie spielen nicht mehr rein, so flaches 4-4-2. Das ist ja ganz, ganz lange gespielt. Aber auch diese RB-Schule, die Merzad Zelenbergovic so ein bisschen von Achim Bayer-Lorz übernommen hatte, die löst sich so langsam ein bisschen mehr auf. Er lässt so ein bisschen mehr sein eigenes Ding spielen. Und Ringburg spielt halt ein ziemlich radikales Pressing, das auch mal den Gegner nach innen ableitet und nicht nach außen. Und wenn das funktioniert, ist es super, weil dann hast du sofort den Ball zentral und musst gar nicht lang aufbauen. Aber wenn du überspielt wirst, ist der Gegner halt auch schnell mal vorne. Und das ist durchaus auch so was, wo es halt auch mal schief gehen kann. Und das ist sicherlich auch ein Element zusätzlich noch gewesen. Und ansonsten, die kommen dann auch viel über die Füße. Also eben auch im Rahmen dieses Pressings, du hast mit Gimba, mit Kennedy, mit Breitkreuz, das sind schon auch alles bullige Spieler, denen du eben in irgendeiner Form begegnen kannst, so wie der Klubsgezern hat, mit viel Wendigkeit und Wuseligkeit und Wildheit. Aber ja, es ist so ein bisschen Glück und Pech, dass es sich dann irgendwie ausgleicht. Und die Standards sind, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen in den letzten Wochen ein bisschen weniger gefährlich geworden, als sie das am Anfang waren.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, die zweite Halbzeit, das haben ja auch die Beobachter, die rund um den Jahren aktiv sind, gesagt, die war schon ziemlich desillusionierend, also die zweite Halbzeit vom Nürnberg-Spiel. Und natürlich, Florian, ich gebe dir komplett recht, sie waren auf einer Euphoriewelle unterwegs, sie haben teilweise über ihre eigenen Möglichkeiten gespielt. Und deshalb müssen sie jetzt nur bedingt Sorgenverhalten haben. Aber ich finde, die Situation ist eben trotzdem sehr, sehr schwierig mit diesem Antilauf, den sie da gerade haben. Ohne den starken Saisonstart wären sie jetzt definitiv abstiegsgefährdet. Ich sehe das Düsseldorf-Spiel, was jetzt ansteht, auch schon ein bisschen als Knack-Spiel, das muss man ganz klar so sagen. Und was ich mir natürlich auch denken kann, das kann ich jetzt nicht belegen. Du hast Weggesser vorhin erwähnt, der nach Nürnberg geht. Sicherlich hat bei dem einen oder anderen Akteur in Regensburg auch mal jemand angefragt und gefragt, wie so die Zukunftsplanung aussieht. Und da könnte der ja auch ins Kübeln gekommen sein. Ich kann mir vorstellen, für den einen oder anderen, gerade jüngeren Spieler, der in der Herbst auf sich aufmerksam gemacht hat, rattert es da auch im Kopf und der sagt sich vielleicht auch, naja, ist jetzt Jan Regensburg mal eine Endstation oder reicht es vielleicht noch mal für einen anderen, für einen namhafteren Zweitligisten? Und das hat vielleicht auch dafür zugesorgt, dass es momentan beim Jan nicht so richtig super läuft.
Ja, um das zu unterstreichen, du hast mit Alexander Mayer, mit Max Besuschkow, mit Jan Elvedi, dann eben mit Weckeser, du hast da schon einen ganzen Schwung an eigentlich gesetzten Spielern, wo der Vertrag ausläuft, dann hast du noch Leihspieler mit Bukalfa, mit Beste, mit Singen, mit Otto, die auch relativ viele Minuten kriegen. Also das ist durchaus was, was eine Rolle spielen kann. Also gerade bei Besuschkow kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass der noch mal in Regensburg verlängert. Und der ist eigentlich fürs Spiel schon auch zentral.
Ja, ich glaube, das fasst das ganz gut zusammen. Da gibt es ein paar offene Fragen, viele offene Fragen, aber auch ein paar Antworten gibt es bei Hannover 96. Jens, die haben eine bemerkenswerte Entwicklung mitgenommen. Christoph Tabrowski ist da neuer Trainer, also eigentlich gar nicht mehr so neu. Das war ab dem 15. Spieltag. Lasse ich mir die Christoph Tabrowski-Tabelle erstellen. Dann liegt Hannover 96 auf Rang 9, hat 11 Punkte gesammelt, genauso viele wie zum Beispiel Heidenheim und Karlsruhe. Drei Siege, zwei Unentschieden, nur zwei Niederlagen, ein ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis. Es begann alles schon mal mit einem 1 zu 0 gegen den HSV. Das war jetzt noch vor der Winterpause. Und Hannover 96, das muss man wirklich sagen, ist jetzt beständig geklettert und vor allem ist die Mannschaft, die für überraschende Ergebnisse sorgt.
Ja, Max, nehmen ihn doch nicht den Pokalsieg noch weg. Also ich würde sagen, vier Siege unter Christoph Damprowski. Und die sind so glücklich, dass sie im Pokal weitergekommen sind. Gegen Gladbach haben sie da die nächste Runde erreicht. Ja, wir können ja über alle Trainerwechsel in der 2. Liga sprechen. Die waren fast alle erfolgreich. Also es gab ja neulich mal beim Kicker diese Tabelle. Und der Punkteschnitt des Nachfolgers ist erfolgreich. Das ist in der Bundesliga nicht so, aber in der 2. Liga haben die Trainerwechsel allesamt was gebracht.
Außer André Schubert.
Außer André Schubert, ja, das sprechen wir jetzt vom Nachfolger. Ingolstadt ist ja schon wieder ein neuer Trainer am Start. Aber sie sind defensiv stabiler. Das merkt man. Sie haben zum vierten Mal unter Damprowski zu Null gespielt. Er hat eine Konstanz reingebracht. Also jetzt nicht konstanz auf ganz hohem Niveau. Er will ja irgendwann mal aufsteigen. Aber man merkt ganz deutlich, Hannover 96 ist taktisch unausrechenbarer geworden. Zuletzt jetzt gegen St. Pauli sogar mit Dreierkette gespielt. Und ich glaube, die werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr lange um den Relegationsplatz, also unten um Platz 16 mitspielen.
Es ist spannend, weil ich habe mir so ein bisschen mal die Daten rausgelassen und verglichen zwischen Zimmermann und Dabrowski. Und da fällt halt auf, eigentlich spielen sie ein ganzes Stück passiver, weil sie dem Gegner mehr Ballbesitz lassen, lassen mehr Pässe zu. Aber sie spielen viel, viel direkter. Also sie kommen viel besser zum Abschluss. Und das ist schon auffällig, dass man so viel Unterschied zwischen zwei Trainern wirklich ablesen kann. Das kommt gar nicht so oft vor in der Kürze der Zeit. Also er hat da wirklich –und Max, das wird dir gefallen –sie haben auch die Flanken deutlich zurückgefahren.
Ja, aber eins, was auffällt, sie wollten sich ja von Zimmermann eigentlich auch nicht so schnell trennen. Denn das war ja auch quasi der Wunsch-Trainer oder der Wunsch-Trainer bei Hannover 96. Da kommen wir dann auch zu den Parallelen beim nächsten, vor allem, über den wir sprechen wollen, bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Auch die wollten sich von Christian Preusser nicht trennen. Aber irgendwann, und deshalb haben sie schneller die Notbremse gezogen, kommst du zu dem Entschluss, es funktioniert halt nicht, wir müssen was machen. Und dann haben sie mit Darmkowski offenbar den richtigen Move gemacht in Hannover. Endlich mal.
Ja, beziehungsweise ich will jetzt nicht wieder derjenige sein, der Wasser in die Suppe gießt. Aber ich traue dem dann immer nicht so. Ihr habt ja alles wunderbar herausgearbeitet, wie sich das gerade bei vielen Vereinen, die den Trainer gewechselt haben, gariert. Und die Erfahrung der Fußballgeschichte sagt aber, auch da gibt es wieder eine Regression zur Mitte eigentlich. Also statistisch gesehen haben Trainerwechsel langfristig keinen Effekt. Das tut mir so total leid, weil es ist ja schön, dass irgendwie Hannover 96 jetzt auch wieder Spiele gewinnt und dass man eben, wenn die auf St. Pauli spielen, oder wenn die gegen Hannover, Hamburg habe ich vorhin schon genannt, aber die haben ja auch noch gegen Vardar, gut, das war nicht so 1 zu 4, aber es ist einfach jetzt wieder offen, wie ein Hannover 96-Spiel ausgeht.
Ostfork haben sie auch gewonnen.
Stimmt, aber trotzdem traue ich dem Ganze nicht so. Ich habe das, ob das nicht so nur so kurzfristige Mitnahmeeffekte des Trainerwechsels sind, die es ja dann durchaus gibt.
Nö, ist ja schön, dass du jetzt kurz nochmal Wikipedia für Trainerwechsel gemacht hast. Und Statistiker werden jetzt in die Hände klatschen und sagen, der Max, der hat doch recht. Ja, auf lange Sicht bringt der Trainerwechsel wenig, aber auf kurze Sicht will Martin Kind Erfolg sein und will mit seiner Mannschaft weiter in der 2. Bundesliga bleiben. Und da sehe ich sie momentan in einer ganz guten Stellung im Vergleich zu einigen anderen Vereinen. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, direkter Abstieg müssen wir nicht mehr drüber reden. Ich glaube, die Kandidaten stehen fest. Und den Relegationsplatz haben sie für mich auch eine relativ gute Ausgangsposition. Also da hat Dabrowski schon was reingebracht. Und er kennt natürlich auch das ganze Umfeld rund um den Marschsee. Der ist da versiert. Und dem musst du das nicht noch mal alles neu erklären, wie Hannover 96, wie speziell Hannover 96 funktioniert. Das ist ja nun doch ein bisschen anders als bei manchem anderen Verein.
Ja, sehr guter Punkt. Das stimmt natürlich. Und man hat jetzt drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz und 13 Punkte Vorsprung auf den direkten Abstiegsplatz. Das war das, was du schon angesprochen hast. Da muss man sich jetzt nicht mehr die großen Sorgen machen. Und es ist ja richtig, dass man sich Sorgen gemacht hat. Die Lage war ja sportlich gesehen alles andere als gut. Und das baut uns auch eine Brücke zu Fortuna Düsseldorf. Du hast es schon angesprochen, Jens, dass wir gleich auch nur über die sprechen wollen. Denn da haben wir etwas, ich weiß nicht, Flo, Vergleichbares. Den Ergebnissen nachher, ja, auch da haben wir einen Trainerwechsel. Auch da haben wir Justamente Siege danach.
Justament sechs Punkte aus zwei Spielen. Also das ist schon spannend, dass es so funktioniert. Um deinen Punkt auch noch mal aufzugreifen. Also zum einen ist es natürlich, statistisch ist es meistens so, aber es gibt tatsächlich ja 15 bis 20 Prozent der Trainer, die tatsächlich einen Effekt haben. Vielleicht hat ja zumindest der ein oder andere einen von diesen Trainern erwischt. Das kann ja genauso sein. Zum anderen muss man ja auch sagen, manchmal reicht ja auch dieser kurze Mitnahmeeffekt. Dass du einfach sagst, die drei Punkte oder die fünf Punkte, die ich jetzt mehr hole, das sind genau die, die mir dann dafür sorgen, dass du eben nicht auf diesem 16. Platz langst und die Lotterie mit der Relegation nach unten, die hat man in Nürnberg ja auch nur sehr, sehr knapp überstanden. Und der will sich keiner aussetzen. Also von daher, ich kann das schon nachvollziehen. Also in Nürnberg hat man ja auch dann nach dem 34. Spieltag vor der Relegation noch mal Trainer gewechselt und das mitzunehmen. Also von daher, das nur anschließend an sich. Und Daniel June ist natürlich jetzt auch so jemand, wo man sagt, der war bis letztes Jahr noch beim HSV und da hatte man so die Frage, ob der die in die Bundesliga führt. Also das ist schon auch jemand, dem man das durchaus zutrauen kann. Andererseits muss man natürlich noch dazu sein, Düsseldorf hat natürlich auch personell was getan, also mit Gintzek, mit Govary, mit De Weis, das sind ja alles Leute, die sofort Stammspieler waren. Also da hat sich ja auch im Personal noch mal was gewandelt in der Winterpause. Und das dann beides zusammen ist dann schon was jetzt, muss ich schon wieder mit Flanken anfangen, weil Düsseldorf sehr, sehr viel flankt, also die Mannschaft mit den meisten Flanken. Und da hat man dann mit Gavurija jetzt auch noch jemanden geholt, mit der dessen Flanken etwas präziser sind, als das, was mit Kudris und Hartherz da vorher auf der Position als Linksverteidiger gespielt hat.
Jens, wie würdest du die Situation bei der Fortuna einschätzen? Also 2 zu 1 gegen Schalke, das war schon mal ein richtig gutes Spiel.
Ich kann es eigentlich auch nur bestätigen. Daniel Thun scheint dort einen guten Job zu machen, hat jetzt, wie gesagt, die ersten beiden Spiele gewonnen. Und das hat Florian gerade gesagt, sie haben sich gut verstärkt mit Ginzeg unter anderem. Und deshalb zeigt auch dort der Daumen aktuell nach oben bei der Fortuna aus Düsseldorf. Aber da würde ich jetzt noch nicht ganz so optimistisch sein wie bei Hannover 96. Mal schauen.
Ja, Jan Regensburg ist so ein bisschen der Lackmustest der 2. Liga, muss man schon sagen. Wenn du gegen die bestehen kannst, dann hast du ein solides Fundament. Wenn du gegen die verlierst, dann bist du unter der Position, auf der Jan Regensburg steht, nämlich unter Rang 10. Hätte ich jetzt mal als These in den Raum geworfen. Gut, ich höre keinen Widerspruch. Und gleichzeitig weckt das aber auch das Bedürfnis, dass wir jetzt endlich über Dynamo Dresden mal ausführlicher sprechen. Das wird aller, aller höchste Zeit. Dynamo liegt mit 26 Punkten ein Punkt vor dem Relegationsplatz, hat aus den letzten fünf Spielen vier Unentschieden geholt, hat jetzt schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr gewonnen. Jens, du hast aber vorhin ja auch schon beim Heidenheim-Spiel, das war jetzt das letzte von Dynamo, das Ganze in einen Kontext eingeordnet, in den Kontext der Spiele nämlich. Gibt es denn Unterschied zwischen Tabellen, Konstellationen und den letzten Ergebnissen und der Art und Weise, wie Dresden gespielt hat?
Würde ich schon sagen. Also aktuell ist es sehr, sehr schwierig bei Dynamo Dresden und speziell in der Offensive ist es schwierig. Man ist aktuell das offensivschwächste Team im Jahr 2022 und da klemmt ganz speziell der Schuh bei Dynamo. Man ist ausrechenbar. Man muss eigentlich nur sich als Gegner auf Christoph Daferner konzentrieren und das macht es für die Gegner dann relativ einfach. Sie sind super in die Saison reingekommen, haben die ganze Aufstiegsäuferie mitgenommen. Ich kann ja noch mal kurz zurückspulen. Sie waren nach vier Spieltagen ganz oben mit mit diesen zehn Punkten. Der Auswärtssieg in Rostock hat für Höhenflüge auch hier in Dresden gesorgt. Dann hat sich allerdings mit Tim Knipping ein wichtiger Abwehrspieler verletzt und auch einer der Spieler, die zu dem Prädikat Führungsspieler gereicht. Das hat dann erst mal ein bisschen reingeschlagen ins Kontor. Und dann kam eben dieser Negativ-Trend. Neun Spiele ohne Sieg, davon viele Niederlagen. Das hat vieles verändert in Dresden. Dann ist man im Spätherbst zurückgekommen, hat Siege eingefahren gegen Düsseldorf, Karlsruhe und Aue. Aber man hat längst nicht mehr so offensiv stark gespielt wie im Spätsommer. Man hat auch nicht mehr so früh gepresst. Da ist ein bisschen die Dynamo DNA abhandengekommen. Deshalb ist auch die jetzige Situation eine Situation, die viele mit den Stirn runzeln lässt. Auch der Trainer Alexander Schmidt wird langsam dünnhäutiger hier in Dresden. Man macht sich langsam Sorgen, oder langsam ist vielleicht übertrieben gesagt, ob das was wird mit dem direkten Klassenerhalt. Es geht nur darum, drin zu bleiben. Platz 15 zu erreichen, das ist das große Ziel des Vereins. Nach mehr hat man sowieso nicht geschaut. Das will man jetzt irgendwie erreichen. Aber die nächsten Gegner sind richtig brutal schwer. Darmstadt jetzt am Samstag, dann geht es weiter zu Werder Bremen. Auch ein richtig schweres Auswärtsspielen. Dann kommt St. Pauli, also drei Aufstiegskandidaten am Stück. Das wird nicht einfach. Der Druck und die Unruhe ist in Dresden schon latent vorhanden.
Ich habe von außen betrachtet den Unterschied zwischen Hin- und Rückserie aufgemacht an den beiden Rostock-Spielen. Das eine war der 3-1-Auswärtssieg. Man war auch noch vier Spieltagen ungeschlagen. Du hast das jetzt schon wunderbar abgerissen in deinem Schnelldurchlauf dieser bisherigen Spielzeit. Jetzt wurde das konterkariert durch dieses 1-4. Und das auch noch zu Hause gegen Rostock. Wenn du sagst, dass ein paar Elemente der Spielphilosophie von Dynamo verloren gegangen sind, glaubst du, das ist jetzt eine temporäre Anpassung? Hat sich da etwas Grundlegendes verändert? Weil es scheint mir so zu sein, im größeren Rahmen, wenn ich auf Dynamo Dresden gucke, dass das mit der wichtigste Faktor ist für die Frage, ob ein Trainer länger Erfolg hat bei Dynamo oder nicht. Ob er es schafft, diesen Spielstil, der auch sehr auf Heimstärke und auf... Also es ist sehr unangenehm, gegen Dresden zu spielen. Oder es sollte unangenehm gegen Dresden zu spielen. Es sollte so sein. Darauf muss es ja irgendwie dann doch immer beruhen. Glaubst du, das ist jetzt nur so eine Zwischenphase?
Ja, und das ist die große Frage, die sich alle stellen. Wir diskutieren das auch hin und her. Er hat natürlich ein bisschen seine Taktik verändert. Er lässt nicht mehr so früh pressen. Er wartet jetzt auch teilweise manchmal ab. Gegen Hannover 96 war es ganz klar. Da wollten sie erst mal auf jeden Fall einen Punkt holen. Und genauso nach diesem 1-4-Debakel sind sie nach Paterborn gefahren und haben gesagt, okay, wir gucken erst mal, dass wir den halben Mannschaftsbus hinten reinstellen und nach vorne, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, dass wir irgendwas hinbekommen. Das war ja das Spiel, wo auch da Ferner gefehlt hat. Da ging offensiv gar nichts. Und diese Offensivstärke ist momentan eben nicht vorhanden. Das hat auch den Grund, dass du neben da Ferner ganz, ganz wenig Spiele hast, die mal Tore schießen. Jetzt hat man Waslaw Drücherl von Sparta Park geholt. Der funktioniert noch gar nicht. Der hat im Testspiel gegen Erzgebirge Aue zwei Treffer geschossen, aber danach eben noch nicht viel gezeigt, dass er ein torgefährlicher Stürmer ist. Und das macht es unheimlich schwierig. Und du hast gesagt, dieses 1 zu 4 gegen Hansa Rostock, das hat ins Kontor reingeschlagen. Also diese ersten 18 Minuten, da dachtest du, was ist denn hier los? Also so ein Heimspiel oder so eine Anfangsphase habe ich lange nicht erlebt. Und das aus den Klamotten zu schütteln, die Spieler sagen natürlich, klar, haben wir längst abgeschüttelt. Aber das bleibt natürlich auch so ein bisschen haften. Und wenn du in Dresden spielst, ist das immer geil, weil die Fans stehen eigentlich hinter dir. Aber wenn du dann mal zurückliest, dann wird es auch latent unruhig. Und das merkt man auch, spürt auch die Mannschaft.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte man das jetzt...
Darf ich was fragen?
Natürlich.
Weil ich fand, weil Dreschall jetzt angesprochen ist, mein Tschechisch ist so schlecht, ich weiß nicht, ob die Aussprache richtig ist, es sind jetzt im Winter drei Leute geholt worden, die ich jetzt als Jung einstufen würde. Glaubst du, dass das für die Situation der richtige Move ist? Oder hat jemand mit Sohn und Hussein eher ältere Spieler abgegeben? War das für die Struktur der Mannschaft nötig? Oder ist es etwas, wo man sagt, die sind halt so gut? Batista Mayer und Fein, das bringt was? Oder wäre es anders, besser gewesen?
Bei Batista Mayer, das ist auch ein Transfer für die Zukunft. Den hat man jetzt nicht nur mit Blick auf die Rückrunde verpflichtet, sondern auch auf die weiteren Spielzeiten. Der ist ja fest verpflichtet worden. Bei Trichal ist es eine Ausleihe. Da wird man dann im Sommer gucken, ob das weitergeht oder nicht. Und bei Fein, da hat man natürlich ein bisschen Pech gehabt, dass der dann gleich eine Corona-Infektion hatte und jetzt wieder herangeführt werden kann. Wir haben in Hamburg gesehen –ich nehme jetzt das Wort später, da werden einige die Augen verdrehen –was das für ein Feiner Fußballer ist. Aber er muss jetzt irgendwann mal die Chance und die Möglichkeit bekommen. Da warten alle in Dresden darauf, dass der hier explodieren kann. Und Alexander Schmidt, Dynamo-Trainer, hat gesagt, der hilft uns selbst, wenn er nur sechs, sieben Spiele spielen kann, hilft uns diese Ausleihe unheimlich weiter. Hoffentlich bald, hoffentlich ist er bald in der Lage, Fußball zu spielen. Wir wissen alle, so eine Corona-Infektion kann danach auch ein bisschen noch dauern, bis man dann wieder das volle Level, die 100 Prozent erreicht haben. Das haben wir jetzt zuletzt bei Olympia gesehen. Du schnippst nicht gleich mit dem Finger und bist dann gleich wieder fit. Das dauert auch manchmal ein paar Tage. Da sind sie jetzt dran, den Fein hinzubekommen. Dann könnte der für die Offensive auf jeden Fall eine echte Belebung sein. Mit Weihrauch war ja auch ein Spieler jetzt dabei zuletzt, der lange gefehlt hat, der verletzungsbedingt gefehlt hat, den man jetzt auch wieder so ranführt. Tim Knipping, ich hatte es gesagt, der sich in Rostock schwer verletzt hat, wird jetzt auch kommen, der wird auch sein Comeback demnächst geben. Also er wird wieder mehr personelle Alternativen haben. Sebastian May, den ehemaligen Kapitän, bringt er jetzt immer mal gerne als Stürmer in den letzten Minuten in der Hoffnung, dass der dann vorne mit seiner Wucht irgendwas erreichen kann. Also er hat ein paar Personalien da und zur Verfügung. Sie müssen Tore schießen, das ist so einfach, aber sie müssen so spielen wie in den letzten 30 Minuten gegen Heidenheim. Dann können sie den direkten Klassenerhalt schaffen, wenn sie so spielen wie in den ersten 50, 60 Minuten, wird es verdammt schwer.
Ich finde das interessant, dass wir so viel über die Offensive sprechen. Also das wundert mich jetzt nicht. Gerade die Abhängigkeit von Christoph Davana haben wir hier auch schon häufiger thematisiert im Rasenfunk. Denn auf der anderen Seite hast du ja schon angesprochen, man hat sich jetzt in zwei Spielen auch dazu entschieden, du hast gesagt, den Bus zu parken. Und da könnte man ja auch argumentieren, ja das hat ja herausragend gut funktioniert. Das waren zwei 0-0-Spiele und das mit Hannover und Paderborn, ja auch gegen jetzt nicht irgendwelche Mannschaften. Das ist ja auch eigentlich eine Stärke von Dynamo Dresden. Man hat die sechs beste Defensive gemessen an den Gegentoren. Und aus dem direkten Umfeld der Mannschaften, mit denen man da gerade um den Relegationsplatz sich beigt, ist höchstens noch Hannover und Düsseldorf ungefähr in dieser Nähe. Alle anderen haben da viel größere Probleme. Was macht denn die Defensive von Dresden so gut? Und stimmst du mir dabei zu, wenn ich sage, am Standort Dresden wird das nicht so wirklich wertgeschätzt, weil es halt dann doch wichtiger ist, vorne Alarm zu machen?
Nee, nee, das wird schon wertgeschätzt. Zum Beispiel ein Michael Sollbauer, der ist da für jeden Zweikampf am letzten Freitag auch gefeiert worden. Der Österreicher. Ganz, ganz wichtiger Abwehrspieler, der sich in die Bälle reinwirft. Also das weiß man. Mit einem Kevin Ehlers hat man auch einen Youngster als Abwehrspieler. Akoto ist auch sehr, sehr gut. Also man hat auf jeden Fall ein paar Möglichkeiten. Was natürlich bei der Defensive immer manchmal so reinschlägt, ist, dass er die Ketten dort hinten immer mal ändern muss, weil der eine oder andere Spieler mal gesperrt ist oder mal sich eine gelb-rote Karte abholt. Da muss er dann personell flexibel agieren. Aber da gebe ich dir komplett recht. Die Defensive ist aktuell nicht die Baustelle. Es ist wirklich die Offensive. Jetzt muss man mal gucken, wie sie den Ausfall von Chris Löwe verkraften können, der verletzt ist. Der war ein sehr stabiler Spieler von der Form her in der Hinrunde. Der ist auch ein sehr erfahrener Spieler. Der wird ihn sicherlich abgehen. Der wird wahrscheinlich erst im Saison-Endspurt wieder zum Zuge kommen. Das tut sicherlich weh. Aber mit Ausfällen haben alle Mannschaften in der 2. Liga zu kämpfen. Das werden sie verkraften und das müssen sie verkraften. Da wird Alexander Schmidt die richtigen Antworten dann auch personell finden. Das muss er auch.
Wie sieht es denn bei Kevin Broll aus? Wie lange braucht der noch, bis er wieder zurück ist? Die 0-0 haben alle mit Mitruschkin erzielt worden.
Ganz ehrlich, noch mal ganz kurz zu Mitruschkin. Mitruschkin tat mir nach der 18. Minute im Rostock-Spiel richtig leid. Beim 3. Tor hatte er eine Teilaktie mit dran, aber ansonsten konnte er bei den Toren nichts machen. Dann hält er noch richtig gut gegen Rostock. Er ist ein guter Keeper, aber Proll hat eine ganz andere Körpersprache und ist eigentlich die klare Nummer 1 gehört. Für mich auch zu den besten Keepern in der 2. Bundesliga. Wie lange das dauert, das kann ich dir ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen. Man sagte ja vor dem Rostock-Spiel, das ist eine Tag-zu-Tag-Entscheidung. Man ist ja davon ausgegangen, dass er vielleicht gegen Rostock spielen kann. Das Rostock-Spiel liegt jetzt auch schon eine Zeit zurück. Dann hat er gegen Rostock nicht gespielt, er hat gegen Impada Born nicht gespielt und auch gegen Heidenheim nicht gespielt. Jetzt schauen wir mal, was am Wochenende ist. Alexander Schmidt, Frage 2 oder 3 wird sein, wie sieht es denn bei Kevin Proll aus? Und möglicherweise sagt er uns, er ist noch weiter in der Reha. Also zu Wochenbeginn war Kevin Proll noch in der Reha. Mal schauen, wie lange die Reha ist. Es ist auf jeden Fall eine hartnäckige Handverletzung, die sich Dynamos Nr. 1 dazu gezogen hat.
Ja, und durchaus ein wichtiger Faktor im Kampf gegen den Abstieg. Wir haben vorhin schon ganz kurz über ihn gesprochen, aber das würde mich jetzt abschließend noch interessieren. Wie siehst du denn die Position von Alexander Schmidt, dem Trainer? Ist im letzten April gekommen, also April letzten Jahres, meine ich damit. Du hast vorhin gesagt, man hebt jetzt so ein bisschen die Augenbrauen. Das ist ja noch relativ verhalten, würde ich sagen, das ist ein ganz anderes Dresdenumfeld.
Es ist ganz unterschiedlich. Manche schimpfen nur noch. Da ist ganz, ganz schlimmes Schimpfen angesagt. Manche sagen, ja, lasst ihn mal, der wird das Ding schon wuppen. Im Herbst stand er nach der Niederlage in Kiel schon zur Debatte. Da hat man gesagt, nein, wir machen mit Alexander Schmidt weiter. Weil Ralf Becker und Alexander Schmidt haben auch ein gutes Verhältnis miteinander. Da hat man darauf gesetzt, okay, Dynamo wird sich wieder berappeln. Und dann nach den Siegen, ich hatte es schon gesagt, gegen Düsseldorf, gegen Karlsruhe und Aue hat man sich bestätigt gefühlt. Und jetzt, wenn er erneut so eine Serie hinlegt, glaube ich nicht, dass er das so überstehen wird. Also, ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, Ralf Becker hat ja auch im Vorjahr in der 3. Liga noch dann reagiert, als es mit Markus Kautzinski überhaupt nicht mehr ging. Ich glaube, der guckt sich ganz genau das an. Der Sportchef von Dynamo Dresden hört in die Mannschaft rein, spricht auch mit den Spielern. Und wenn er dann irgendwie das Gefühl hat, das funktioniert nicht mehr, dann wird er möglicherweise auch zu diesem Entschluss greifen und dann noch mal was machen. Aktuell, würde ich sagen, steht er nicht direkt zur Disposition. Aber ich habe die nächsten Gegner erwähnt. Also Darmstadt, Bremen und wie gesagt St. Pauli ist jetzt nicht die einfachste Kost in der 2. Bundesliga. Und nur mit Unentschieden, weil ich jetzt vorhin gesagt habe, ja ist ja toll, haben ja jetzt mal Unentschieden gespielt. Nur mit Unentschieden kommst du nicht weiter. Du wartest eben seit dem Derbysieg in Auer und der war glücklich, Martin Mendel sei Dank. Wartest du auf einen Sieg bei Dynamo Dresden und deshalb wären die Leute auch unzufrieden. Sie werfen ihm auch ein paar personelle Entscheidungen vor, ein bisschen auch das Taktische, dass er eben nicht mehr so spielt, wie er zu Beginn der Saison gespielt hat. Und er wird ein bisschen dünnhäutig.
Und wie würdest du das bewerten? Denn von außen betrachtet könnte man ja auch sehr gut argumentieren, er sollte den Aufstieg schaffen als Nachfolger von Kowcinski. Das hat er geschafft. Er soll Dresden in der Liga halten. Da ist man noch voll im Rennen mit dabei, dass man da nicht vorneweg spazieren würde im etabellen Mittelfeld. Das war ja auch allen klar.
Der Saisonstart hat vielen Menschen auch Sand in die Augen gestreut. Das muss man ganz klar so sagen. Dieser tolle Spätsommer. Deshalb sagen jetzt manche, sie hätten viel weiter umstehen müssen. Diese Liga ist brutal schwer. Wenn du am Ende 15er bist, kannst du einen dicken Haken hinter diese Saison machen und sagen, Saisonziel erreicht. Ich würde es jetzt nicht nur am Tabellenstand, sondern auch in der Spielweise festmachen. Wenn du irgendwann das Gefühl hast, dass du nicht mehr viele Tore schießt und dass der Trainer vielleicht die Mannschaft nicht mehr so erreicht, dann wirst du handeln. Aber er sagt ja selbst, das betonte er bei jeder Pressekonferenz, er und die Mannschaft sind eine feste Einheit. Er steht 100 Prozent zu der Mannschaft. Die nächsten Spiele werden es weisen. Es wird ein heißer März hier in Dresden.
Was macht er denn eigentlich in der Ansprache vor dem Spiel, wenn man in der ersten halben Stunde genau ein Tor erschießt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass er da irgendwelche Bibelferse vorliest. Aber sicherlich wird auch er das hinterfragen, dass da vielleicht irgendwas nicht so funktioniert. Wobei ich sagen muss, Hamburg ist ja momentan das Beispiel, wo ich sage, es geht doch auch im Jahr 2022. Gegen den HSV sind sie rausgekommen und haben herzerfrischenden Offensiv-Fußball gespielt. Da haben sie Hamburg gepresst, da haben sie sie unter Druck gesetzt. Da standen sie auch selbst nicht unter Druck. Und so will ich eigentlich Dynamo Dresden sehen. Und da haben sie auch das Publikum, was wenig war, aber das haben sie da an dem Abend auch mitgenommen. Und deshalb, wenn sie das Hamburg-Spiel als Blaupause nehmen, dann könnte es wie gesagt was werden. Aber er muss einfach auch wieder zum Mut zurückgewinnen, wie der Alexander Schmidt. Dann glaube ich, dass auch seine Mannschaft wieder mutiger auftreten wird.
Das Hamburg-Spiel als Blaupause nehmen. Da hast du mir mal wieder ganz der Moderationsprofi die Überleitung zum nächsten Team geliefert, über das wir sprechen wollen. Denn auch der SV Sandhausen würde gerne dieses 1 zu 1 vom Wochenende sicherlich als Blaupause nehmen. Und im Grunde hat er das aber eigentlich auch schon getan. Also wenn wir über Bilbel-Ferse bei Alexander Schmidt sprechen, da würde ich gerne wissen, was Alois Schwarz eigentlich in den letzten acht Spielen seinen Spielern so gesagt hat. Aus den letzten acht Spielen nur eine Niederlage, drei Siege, vier Unentschieden. Damit hat sich Flo Sandhausen in der Tabelle raus aus der direkten Abstiegszone hin auf den Relegationsplatz gerobbt. Und da liegt man jetzt eben. Und deswegen wird es ja auch so dramatisch für manchen Verein davor, dass jetzt manche anfangen zu punkten, wie Hannover und Fortuna, und Sandhausen jetzt schon eine ganze Weile von hinten rausschiebt. Was hat sich denn da deiner Meinung nach verändert?
Es ist irgendwie, ja, Alois Schwarz spielt Alois Schwarzigen Fußball. Und das funktioniert in dieser Tabellenzone ziemlich gut. Also wenig Ballbesitz, defensiv aber mega stabil. Also wenn man sich das anguckt, haben sie jetzt im Winter mit Dumic auch noch mal einen Verteidiger geholt, wo man sagt, boah, der gewinnt irgendwie 80 Prozent seiner Defensiv-2-Kämpfe. Und auch in der Luft ist der riesig. Also das ist halt dann doch was, wo man sagt, da hat sich dann auch der Trainerwechsel, um den Bogen zu spannen, hat sich da auch gelohnt, weil da ganz, ganz viel besser geworden ist. Also es ist so, ich habe ja Alois Schwarz in Nürnberg auch mal erleben müssen oder dürfen oder können. Und der Fußball sieht eigentlich genauso aus. 4-1, 4-1, wir stehen sicher und schauen halt, dass wir vorne irgendwie das Ding reinmurmeln. Möglichst wenig Gegentore kassieren. Das ist so das eine. Und sie haben halt dann im Winter, das ist das andere, auch ordentlich was gemacht. Sie haben Dumitsch, habe ich schon angesprochen, dann Tribol, Berko, Deville, Säufert, Kutucu, also das gleich ordentlich eingekauft im Winter, da noch mal ein bisschen was verändert. Neben Dumitsch, Tribol und Berko haben schon ordentliche Einsatzzeiten gesehen. Da merkt man eben dann auch so, sie haben auch noch mal was getan im Winter. Und dann eben, jetzt kriegen sie auch die Ergebnisse. Das jetzt gegen den HSV gut aussehen, das hat ja quasi schon Tradition. Aber an sich schon, gerade so die Stabilisierung unter Schwarz in der Defensive ist schon da, nach vorne könnte immer noch mehr gehen. Da ist man halt, man kommt ein bisschen selten in den Strafraum, hat halt testrot und das war's. Das ist schon noch was, weshalb sie auch jetzt wahrscheinlich bis zum Ende da unten drin hängen werden.
Der Testrot ist aber kein schlechter, das muss man einfach mal so sagen. Er sorgt für die Tore, die anderen Mannschaften, über die wir vielleicht auch noch reden, abgehen. Und ich sag mal, sie kommen auch mit den Umständen jetzt ganz gut klar. Sie waren ja auch ein bisschen gehandicapt, hatten dann eine längere Pause. Gerade als Karlsruhe in der Corona-Pause war, hatten sie sich ehlendelang auf das nächste Spiel vorzubereiten und haben erst eine Niederlage im Jahr 2022. Kassiert sind das sechs beste Rückrundenteam. Du hast es gerade genannt, du hast die ganzen Neuzugänge erwähnt. Wenn du acht Neuzugänge in der Winterpause hast, dann weißt du, okay, da ist in der Hinrunde was schiefgelaufen. Aber dann bist du auch eine ganz, ganz andere Mannschaft, bist unausrechenbarer für die Gegner. Und die müssen sich komplett neu und anders auf dich einstellen. Und damit hast du deine Grundstruktur geändert. Und wenn sie jetzt, das macht ja momentan den Eindruck, Heimstärke gewinnt, das wird dir an Dresden nicht eingefallen, dann sind sie auf einem guten Weg, vielleicht auch noch von dem Relegationsplatz runterzuspringen. Weil jetzt haben sie gegen Aue gewonnen, gegen Hamburg einen Punkt geholt. Ja, sie wirken sehr stabil. Sandhausen ist, was Sandhausen ist in den letzten Jahren immer wieder. Sie schaffen es irgendwie dann doch noch, die Kurve zu bekommen.
Und Platz 4 in der Auswärtstabelle ist schon wirklich, das ist schon wirklich krass. Also 18 seiner 25 Punkte hat Sandhausen auswärts geholt und ist deswegen eben punktgleich mit Hansa Rostock, die auf Rang 15 davor liegen und eben nur einen Punkt hinter Dresden, hinter Düsseldorf, drei Punkte hinter Nürnberg 96. Also das, was wir oben haben mit dem Aufstiegsrennen, das haben wir unten mit dem Rennen um den Relegationsplatz. Ich denke, das muss man so deutlich formulieren, weil, Jens, du hast es vorhin auch schon angesprochen, Ingolstadt und Aue, die haben abreißen lassen, obwohl Ingolstadt jetzt sogar Punkte sammeln konnte. Du hast aber gerade schon so einen Verweis gemacht, eine Mannschaft, die vorne Probleme hat, Tore zu schießen. Könnte es sein, dass du damit Erzgebirge Aue, unser letztes Team, gemeint hast, über das wir sprechen wollen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich weiß nicht, von welcher Serie Aue und Ingolstadt träumen in den verbleibenden Elfspielen, zehn Punkte wettzumachen. Das müsste ja eine Serie eines Aufsteigers werden. Ich kann es mir in der Liga bei den beiden Mannschaften ganz, ganz schwer vorstellen. In Aue wird mittlerweile offen über das Thema Abstieg gesprochen, wie man damit vielleicht umgehen sollte. Dass man sich dann langsam darauf vorbereitet, wenn man so zwischen den Zeilen bei Martin Mennel liest. Natürlich sagen sie noch nicht, wir sind abgestiegen. Das sind sie auch rein rechnerisch nicht. Aber wenn man sich die letzten Spiele anschaut, ich habe mir die Partie gegen Holstein Kiel angeschaut, dann sind das ganz klare Kennzeichen eines Absteigers. Du liegst 0 zu 2 hinten, spielst mit 10 Mann, holst dann innerhalb von 5 Minuten diesen Rückstand auf, machst das 2 zu 2 und in der 90. Minute sagt irgendjemand Ding Dong. Ihr kassiert ja jetzt noch das Gegentor 2 zu 3. Und du gehst wieder als Verlierer vom Platz und fragst dich, was sollen wir denn sonst noch machen? Die Fehler liegen zum größten Teil im Saisonstart mit dem Trainer. Das war eine Fehlentscheidung. Das geben sie mittlerweile auch unumwundend zu. Man hat viele erfahrene Spieler oder gute Spieler abgegeben. Mit Breitkreuz, Krüger, Rizzuto und mit dem von mir erwähnten Pascal Testroth. Testroth war ein ganz bitterer Abgang für Erzgebirge Auer, weil der nicht hätte sein müssen. Der Kader ist schlecht zusammengestellt, es ist kaum diese Wismut DNA vorhanden, die sie in den letzten Jahren immer so stark gemacht hat. Und Mark Hänsel ist natürlich auch noch ein Trainer bzw. ein Teamchef, der so seinen Weg sucht. Der kommt sehr, sehr viel über die Motivation, steht dort immer mit der kurzen Hose. Aber natürlich, wenn der auch keinen Erfolg hat, dann wird es natürlich auch für ihn schwierig, das immer wieder seinen Spielern zu erklären. Das ist, wie wenn ich zum Diätberater gehe und ich nehme dann nach dessen Empfehlungen trotzdem nicht ab. Also von daher hat auch er ein ganz, ganz schwieriges Amt. Und die Winterneuzugänge, die haben er nicht so zugelangt wie andere Vereine, wie z.B. Sandhausen oder Düsseldorf, George, Owoso oder Lang. Lang ist nur Perspektive, haben eben auch nicht so richtig funktioniert. Owoso, würde ich mit Abstrichen sagen, der spielt und der macht seine Sache auch ganz solide. Aber bei Erzgebirger Aue kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, wie das noch zum Klassenhalt gereichen soll.
Meine Notiz, die ich für die Sendung gemacht habe, war einfach nur als erstes Steigt-ab-Punkt.
Warum denn das?
Gegen alter Dinge, die du gerade gesagt hast, Jens.
Also um das, was du gesagt hast, Jens, auch aufzugreifen, der Kader ist auch unrund zusammengestellt. Also wenn man sich das mal anguckt, du hast…
Ich habe verstanden, du hast gesagt, dieses Ausrufezeichen steigt ab, also steigt endlich ab.
Nein, nein, es war keine Aua-Partie. Nein, keine Aufforderung. Es war eine Aussage. Ich greife auch gleich nochmal zurück. Also bei Mitrushkin, es war nur ein 0 zu 0, nicht, dass ich wieder wütende Twitter-Meldungen von Dresden-Fans bekomme, weil ich ihm was zuschreibe, was er nicht getan hat. Das andere 0-0 war noch Broll.
Genau, aber jetzt der unrunde Kader von…
Genau, weil du hast nämlich, wenn du dir das anguckst, bei den Einsatzzeiten und so weiter, du kommst halt auf, interessanterweise, du kommst auf knapp 40 Prozent der Einsatzzeiten für die Spieler, die 23 oder jünger sind, und du kommst auf 40 Prozent der Einsatzzeiten für Spieler, die 30 sind oder älter. Und du hast halt dieses Mittelfeld nicht. Und man spricht ja in der Leistungsdiagnostik ganz oft davon, dass so zwischen 24 und 29 das Peak Age ist. Also da, wo das von den Positionen her natürlich immer noch ein bisschen zu unterschiedlichen Innenverteidiger und Torwart haben andere Leistungsspitzen als ein Außenstürmer. Aber du hast halt wenige Spieler in diesem Mittelkorridor zwischen 24 und 29. Da haben sie mit Gay jetzt noch einen abgegeben. Aber gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht so tragisch. Aber du hast in diesem Korridor eigentlich mit Strauß und mit Abstrichen Barilla eigentlich nur zwei Spieler, die wirklich viel spielen. Und ansonsten hast du viele junge und viele alte. Und dazwischen eigentlich quasi ganz wenig. Und dieses Unrunde ist halt auch problematisch für einen Kader, wenn du bei den Spielern mit der Leistungshoch-Zusammensetzung so wenige hast. Der Kader sieht für die Zukunft gar nicht schlecht aus, finde ich. Genau, aber fürs Jetzt halt einfach nicht ausgegoren, weil du halt noch viel auf die älteren Spieler verlassen musst. Gleichzeitig aber die Jungen schon relativ viel übernehmen müssen. Und das ist dann halt schwierig.
Definitiv. Und Florian Ballers zum Beispiel, der erfahrener Abwehrspieler, ist verletzt die ganze Zeit schon. Und weil du gerade gesagt hast, Geh, da muss ich ja drängen, du hast ja schon zwei Spiele abgegeben, die du erst im Sommer geholt hast. Er ist schon wieder abgegeben. Da weißt du ja ganz genau, dass da irgendwas nicht zusammengepasst hat bei der Kader-Zusammenstellung. Aber das Grundübel ist einzig und allein da zu suchen, dass du den falschen Trainer im letzten Sommer geholt hast mit Schipilevski, wo alle gesagt haben, entweder es funktioniert 1a, damals wie mit Domenico Tedesco, oder es wird ein Desaster. Es ist Letzteres geworden.
Das tut einem dann schon ein bisschen leid, da so deutlich den Start zu brechen, aber da sprechen die Ergebnisse eine deutliche Sprache. Aber gut, für die Zukunft ist man ja ganz gut aufgestellt. Und nur um noch das einzurahmen und auch ein bisschen deine Arbeit zu würdigen, Flo, was du gesagt hast mit diesem Mittelbau, mit diesen Spielern zwischen 24 und 29 Jahren, da haben wir eben sehr, sehr wenige Baue. 27 Prozent der Spielzeit, der Einsatzminuten hat diese Alterskohorte gemacht. Der HSV ist da die radikalste Mannschaft. Die haben nämlich 39 Prozent U23 und 61 Prozent in genau dieser Kohorte zwischen 24 und 29. Jeder, der in Mathematik so halbwegs mitgekommen ist, der weiß, oh, U30, da kommen wir auf 0,0 Prozent. Richtig krass, wie das beim HSV aufgetan ist.
Wir haben im ganzen Kader nur einen Spieler über 30, das ist Tom Mikkel. Und das ist, ich glaube, der dritte Torwart. Also das ist ganz, ganz auffällig. Wo es auch relativ auffällig ist, ist St. Pauli. Die sind bei 70 Prozent in diesem Mittelbau. Da könnte man vielleicht auch ein bisschen erklären, warum die jetzt gerade so gut funktionieren, weil die halt viele Spieler haben, die auf ihrem Leistungshoch sind. Also es ist natürlich zu kurz gegriffen, das einfach zu sagen, ja, ich kaufe jetzt einfach nur 24- bis 29-Jährige und dann funktioniert das. Aber es ist halt schon auffällig, dass das bei denen dann auch so ist, dass die sehr viel auf diese Spieler setzen. Und dann gibt es eben die anderen Entwürfe. Dresden ist, um den Bogen noch zu spannen, bei den U23 Minuten sogar erster mit 40,7 Prozent. Wobei da, also muss man immer sagen, U23 heißt halt, du machst einen Stichtag. Und das ist halt bei mir dann in den Aufzeichnungen der 1. Neunte. Da sind dann auch ein paar Spieler dabei, die jetzt 24 geworden sind, die da mit dazu zählen. Aber man kann ja nicht, das ist ja wie bei den Turnieren. Bei den Turnieren, da spielen ja U21-Europameisterschaften, spielen ja U23-Jährige auch mit.
Eben, eben. Aber ich sehe schon, du hast große Angst davor, bei Twitter Reaktionen zu bekommen, wenn du das jetzt hier nochmal erklärst. Ich glaube aber, das ist ja auch alles erst mal nur Zahlenspielerei, aber es ist halt interessant, diese Unterschiede zu sehen. Auch eben dann am anderen Ende der Skala. Sandhausen, die eigentlich kaum nennenswerte U23-Spiele haben, und das machen alles komplett. 67 Prozent in der Alterskorte, 24, 29. Und der Rest sind die U30-Spiele. Das ist so der gegensätzliche HSV. Der HSV macht es nur mit Jungen. Und Sandhausen macht es mit Jungen plus Alten. Also, ist eine interessante Spielerei. Und wirft dann auch noch mal ein besonderes Licht auf den Saisonverlauf auch. Weil man da eben sieht, vielleicht hat die eine oder andere Katerstruktur eine andere Resilienz gegenüber Rückschlägen als die vergleichbaren Mannschaften. Ohne das über bewerten zu wollen. Ihr beiden, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, man hat es der Sendung auch angehört. Ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich. Und ich möchte noch mal eine ausgesprochene Höhrempfehlung für das Rasengeflüster aussprechen. Ich bedanke mich bei Jens Umbreit. Er ist auch der Edjens Umbreit auf Twitter. Folgt ihm dort zahlreich. Jens, danke dir, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk.
Max, das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank, dass ich dabei sein durfte. Wir haben mal ein Rückspiel, ne? Rasengeflüster höre ich dich demnächst auch mal.
Ja, das machen wir auch. Du musst mir nur noch ein Thema darüber haben, über das wir dann sprechen. Am besten eins, über das ich auch sprechen kann. Zur Not schicke ich einfach auch so viele Grafiken rüber, wie es Flo Zenger gemacht hat. Vom Clubfans United, von der Nürnberger Zeitung, im KDEP-Podcast, könnt ihr ihn auch hören. Kann ich auch sehr empfehlen für alle, die beim Club tiefer einsteigen wollen. At flo-zenger auf Twitter, da könnt ihr alle kritiklos werden. Freut es sich schon drauf. Flo, danke dir für deine Zeit und für deine Expertise. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich wie immer nicht nur für eure Aufmerksamkeit, sondern auch für euren Support. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und auch unsere Gäste bekommen davon ein kleines Honorar. rasenfunk.de/supporterscluboderkiosk.rasenfunk.de da könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und jetzt vielleicht wegen dieses Aufrufes tun. Habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund. Und dann bis hoffentlich bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.